And this time not all statements are correct,
but the strongest one of them is,
so if you showed just one single
NP complete problem
requiring exponential time to be solved,
then all NP problems will require
exponential time to solve,
and the reason for that is that all NP complete problems
are connected to each other
using polynomial time reductions,
so if one of them requires exponential time
and another one requires polynomial time,
then that just can not be, because
say if this problem here requires polynomial time,
that would mean that
you can SAT, for example, in polynomial time,
which would then mean that you can solve this problem over here in polynomial time,
and so on and so on.
All problems that are NP complete
are from a viewpoint of polynomial or exponential time
equally hard to solve,
which would also mean that the weaker statement here is true.
Some problems in NP are only solvable in exponential time; yes,
if all NP problems require exponential time,
then there are problems in NP which require exponential time.
Finally, this statement down here;
that is not true.
All problems in NP are only solvable in exponential time.
That is not true.
Not all problems in NP require exponential time.
So remember our picture from before when we said that
P is basically a subset of NP,
so these problems here will still be solvable in polynomial time.
It doesn't matter if there are some problems in here
that require exponential time.
It doesn't effect these problems here in NP.